a bordo del Ocean biker la situación es
cada vez peor 234 migrantes en el
Mediterráneo duermen y comen los pocos
pasteles distribuidos por la tripulación
el barco está en el centro de las
tensiones diplomáticas entre Francia e
Italia París Pide a Roma que asuma sus
responsabilidades
este barco debe ser recibido en Italia
en la actitud actual del gobierno
italiano es inaceptable por lo que
esperamos mientras el barco sigue en
aguas territoriales italianas que Italia
cumpla su parte y respete sus
compromisos europeos el Ocean biking
Lleva más de dos semanas recorriendo el
Mediterráneo Italia se niega a aceptarlo
el martes la primera ministra italiana
Georgia meloni insinuó que Francia había
aceptado que el barco atracara en su
territorio agradecemos a Francia que
comparta la responsabilidad de la
emergencia migratoria que Hasta ahora ha
recaído únicamente sobre los hombros de
Italia y otros países europeos abriendo
sus puertas al Ocean viking córcega esta
lista si es necesario para recibir
temporalmente a la Ocean biking en uno
de sus puertos París y Roma ya se
enfrentaron en torno a la migración Hace
cuatro años anteriormente el barco
aquarius y sus 629 migrantes habían
permanecido varios días en el mar antes
de ser acogidos por España y Francia una
crisis que podría repetirse con el
gobierno italiano de Georgia meloni el
masterchista desde la Segunda Guerra
Mundial